what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch Aldo
Jones's weird trailer something number
two Avengers for parody he hit us up
this morning and we are a slave to
whatever Aldo requests cuz he has more
subscribers than us and we are from LA
and status is all that matters so let's
do this oh but before we do we are gonna
watch a vendor's endgame tomorrow
afternoon our review will be up
Wednesday morning please keep a look out
for that because there's going to be a
short opening sketch nice
[Music]
[Music]
Kentucky Fried Chicken Kentucky Fried
movie Thanks
haha
[Music]
[Music]
you
know that every day the bananas
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
haha
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
that's too bad man
poor Thor's can't catch a break man
that's too bad man Tom Blake Cox you
sponsor a lot of Aldo's videos you know
you must be a really big fan it's a cool
iron spider suit Thomas McCabe [ __ ]
article on dargah lawn looks like a game
of Thrones guy
cool well yeah the credits the credits
are always fun
good patrons good patrons right there I
got so excited I thought he was really
gonna commit to the whole ant-man bid
going up Thanos his butthole oh I
thought we were gonna get a whole scene
I was like oh yes we're gonna see this
play out
although jones-style and all you see it
was like a little x-ray inside the
rectum we have a stick yeah cuz his ass
and also half the universe being snapped
away that's a good double pun there
that's great hell are you talking about
I don't know usually just some nonsense
I love it they also expanded the
Avengers team in this you know we got
shaggy in there we got John we got
Stallone I feel like with that kick-ass
moment he just happened to remember
there was a moment where Aaron
taylor-johnson looks over his shoulder
he's like this could work just sitting
there in your mind waiting for you to
put it as an insert to some video
have you seen Kentucky Fried movie I
have not that scene is making fun of
when he says look it's a toy it's making
fun of the movie Enter the Dragon ooh
yeah mmm
freaky toy and another dragon no it's
too much explaining to do I always
forget that when we're about to watch a
weird trailer that we're about to watch
a dogs taking dubs in the background of
the decimation that's gonna be McGuire's
it's got to the point that when I watch
your trailers I start looking around as
opposed to what's center frame at the
time yeah yeah like what Easter Egg am I
gonna miss I don't think I'll ever get
tired of the fact that you have so much
Tobey Maguire is so much so much
spider-man 3 you keeping it alive for
those of us who appreciate in all of its
quirky goodness I love the banana the
bananas that's my favorite one the
commonness
yeah that's my favorite joke it's a good
word because now when I see them in the
movie I'm probably just gonna think of
this moment the worst is trailer
manipulate yeah
the actual movie and then everybody's
got the hot guy haircut I like that he's
really really and I feel like that's
Aldo Jones's favorite bit is the
Stormbreaker shaves off the side of your
head bit
I want to hear an Aldo Jones car you
know how like honest trailers have
honest Rios commentary I think they'll
be great if you guys had some time if
you specifically have like your own Aldo
Jones commentary yeah see what you were
thinking what the method behind the
madness is or is it gonna ruin the weird
trailer for us might you never know cuz
maybe you'll just find out that it's
just Aldo watching the trailer go ahead
I guess I'm just gonna throw this in and
well thanks Aldo for recommending this
video buddy I really appreciate it man
before we wrap this up I would like to
redo a page from the day shout out for a
man named James stake ins so James
yesterday we shot a reaction to that
Godzilla exclusive clip that premiered
on HBO thinking it would go online right
away gave you shattered in that video
and apparently that video hasn't gone
online so I don't want to put it up
because I'm afraid to get this channel
taken down for doing this so James I
didn't want to say to you my friend that
to shout you out on a weird trailers
more appropriate because you are
probably the weirdest guy that is
pledged to our patreon page you kind of
have this like antisocial behavior that
wants to socialize kind of behavior
you're not like a spider-man 3 children
where thank you
especially aggression yeah you act like
you don't care but you really do care
you know you act like Oh on the surface
all you are is just sarcasm and mean
comments but underneath you're really a
nice guy
you also smoke indoors which is
disgusting and gross I did that for a
couple of years but I judge you now for
doing it and I just want to say that I
like you weird and I hope you never stop
being weird and in the guardzilla one I
said you are king of the metaphorical
monsters because in a lot of ways you
are a disgusting
human being bad guy but I like you that
way I don't know if I'd want to hug you
or date you but I'd fist bump you oh
yeah I cuddle you a little bit maybe
yeah guys check out James Degas in
social media he's always trolling go
check out although Jones's page check
out his patron thanks Aldo for letting
us react to this you guys can subscribe
to the rejection click that notification
bell keep a lookout for our vendors
endgame reviewable there will be a
sketch